it's a very corny path then and very and
very indicative of the time and place
and and and and music that I grew up in
and around and that when I was a kid
this would be I mean really young kid
sort of late 60s and then into the 70s
the the god of my existence was was Bob
Dylan because he it for all sort of
smart ish kids at that time that's who
you cleave to if you weren't a Beatles
fan the Rolling Stones were just to
dance to and if you listen to those
songs and if you sort of paid any
attention to the references he then made
reference to this poet or that poet
whether it was a contemporary like
gallon Ginsberg or somebody like Rambo
or and then you would go out and buy
these books and try to make sense of
them because they meant something to him
and then after you got over the star
worship of merely that guy you started
to read it had nothing to do with school
it had nothing to do with anything other
than this path in that's how it started
with me I was not a particularly
religiously oriented kid as despite my
parents best efforts and the other ride
or the other really serious rider that
been everything to me and means a lot to
me to this day is Philip Roth also you
know Philip Roth would be would have
been my father had Philip Roth not been
and literary intellectual but rather an
orthodontist at North Jersey do you see
I mean he would have moved from Newark
and found his way to her toward Barry
it depends on what age I suppose as a as
an adolescent a last port no I would but
I think that in his you know 60s and 70s
he becomes an even stronger writer a
Wilder rider a more serious a writer at
a different height and this begins for
me with the counter life and then
Sabbath theater and then these American
trilogy novels that everybody knows well
every single one of them is not as good
as the other but it comprises a kind of
latent live peak that usually it's not
possible most writers most artists have
if they're lucky ten fifteen years of
peak creative experience Roth had had
that already and then against all odds
he had something else this is it's very
very rare usually what happens is that
writers or artists late in life can't
match the profundity with the physical
and mental energy that is required to
make use of that and so somebody like
Verdi or Rembrandt or Titian is is the
exception not the rule